Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Laura Comand
Hey, ciao coniglio, ciao!
E adesso lasciami entrare
nel favoloso mondo delle meraviglie!
Ben arrivati a tutti quanti, buongiorno.
(Applausi)
Be', la conoscete tutti la storia, spero.
Quella di Alice,
e il favoloso mondo delle meraviglie,
dello Stregatto, dei palmipedi,
del Cappellaio Matto,
del Bianconiglio, che avete visto;
e di Alice, naturalmente.
Io non sono qua oggi
per sorprendervi o stupirvi
con incantesimi e magie,
che non mi appartengono affatto;
ma semplicemente
per raccontarvi la mia storia,
che è molto vicina a quella di Alice
e al tempo delle fiabe.
Per iniziare mi piacerebbe, intanto,
per rendervi ancora più partecipi,
farvi entrare proprio in questo mondo,
mi piacerebbe un'alzata di mano,
visto che avete visto questo video,
e capire, tra i presenti in sala,
chi si riconosce quotidianamente in Alice
e chi nel coniglio bianco.
Vediamo: quanti conigli bianchi ci sono?
Uhm, abbastanza!
E quante Alice?
Uhhhm, poche Alice!
Poche Alice presenti in sala.
Vabbè dai,
anche il coniglio bianco ha il suo perché.
Dunque, Alice perché? E le fiabe perché?
Perché potrei dirvi che io, come Alice,
sono affetta da sempre, sin da bambina,
da quella malattia incurabile
che è quella di sognare ad occhi aperti,
da sempre.
E questo sognare ad occhi aperti,
nel tempo mi ha portato, poi,
a scelte radicali, molto importanti.
Come quella, di un anno fa,
di licenziarmi, mollare un lavoro sicuro.
Un lavoro in un'azienda strutturata:
avevo un favoloso contratto di lavoro
a tempo indeterminato
che oggi dà molta sicurezza -
e per dirla tutta,
stavo anche molto bene
in questo posto di lavoro;
ma non era più il mio mondo,
non era più il mio mondo favoloso
che sognavo da sempre.
Quindi questo sognare continuo,
sin da bambina,
mi ha portato, nel tempo, a prendere
questa scelta radicale un anno fa,
e per che cosa?
Per realizzare il mio sogno più grande,
che è quello, dopo l'essere
diventata madre -
perché sono diventata mamma
quasi otto anni fa -
di aprire un centro polifunzionale
che io definisco "il centro
polifunzionale delle meraviglie"
perché questo è, a tutti gli effetti.
"Centro polifunzionale":
che cosa si intende?
Perché oggi, quando lo racconto,
ancora vedo che la gente
fa una faccia un po' strana.
Centro polifunzionale
è un luogo di lavoro, in primis,
che mette insieme le persone
per farle lavorare,
mette insieme più progettualità,
mette insieme adulti, bambini,
mette insieme mondo profit e no-profit,
mette insieme i sogni, crea contatti.
Perché la vita è fatta
di incontri, di contatti
tra le persone e anche con le cose.
E questo toccarsi, alle volte,
è così magico, così fantastico
che è come un toccarsi tra stelle,
e succedono scintille: veramente, è così.
Nel mio spazio polifunzionale
che cosa succede?
Ogni giorno è stupore
e meraviglia allo stato puro;
e tutto questo avviene,
sicuramente, perché?
Perché gli spazi,
e quindi non solo le persone e le idee,
sono veramente perfetti.
Sono spazi che, da tempo,
non aspettavano che questo.
Perché il tutto avviene in una casa:
e io, da sempre, sognavo di fare
quello che sto facendo in una casa.
Io ho avuto la grandissima fortuna
di trovare una casa perfetta,
che proprio si adatta perfettamente
a tutto quello che avevo in testa.
È una casa con la C maiuscola,
ed è bellezza ovunque si guardi.
Non lo dico io, lo dicono i testi.
Perché questa casa
è su tutti i testi di architettura.
È stata costruita
nell'immediato dopoguerra
da un grandissimo architetto friulano,
Angelo Masieri, nel '49.
Terminata nel '51 quando ancora a Udine
c'erano le macerie della Guerra.
Questa casa, per tanti anni,
è stata l'abitazione di una famiglia;
e poi, nel tempo, le cose sono cambiate,
le situazioni sono cambiate.
Ma questa casa da circa
tre anni era disabitata;
e io per puro caso,
il favoloso caso che a volte succede,
ho avuto la fortuna
di incontrare questa casa,
o lei ha incontrato me.
Ci siamo proprio incontrati
nel momento giusto,
perché poi le cose accadono
quando devono avvenire,
ed è stupore e meraviglia
ovunque si guardi.
Io vi farò vedere qualche immagine:
ma credetemi, le immagini non rendono
la bellezza di questo luogo.
Che cosa consente?
Consente che le persone arrivino,
vengano per lavorare -
liberi professionisti, di diverso genere -
oppure vengano per stare insieme,
semplicemente, fra le persone.
Adulti e bambini, insieme.
O vengono semplicemente
perché facciamo delle proposte,
dei percorsi di crescita,
dei percorsi di benessere,
per fare stare bene le persone.
Perché le persone
hanno bisogno di stare bene,
e in un luogo di bellezza
tutto questo è ancora più semplice.
Quindi abbiamo una cucina,
come tutte le case,
che è un po' il cuore della casa,
dove quando vogliamo possiamo accomodarci,
prepararci da mangiare,
farci un caffè e stare insieme.
Poi è uno splendore anche fuori:
quindi c'è tanto verde,
ci sono alberi che hanno oltre 60 anni
e raccontano anche solo loro
chissà quante cose,
a volerli anche solo guardare.
E quindi è veramente così,
è proprio stupore e meraviglia
ovunque si guardi.
Tutto questo agevola tantissimo
lo stare bene fra le persone,
che era quello
che io desideravo da sempre:
creare un contenitore
per fare stare bene le persone,
per farle lavorare bene in armonia.
Ed è così: noi lì, ogni giorno,
stiamo bene insieme,
fra le persone, fra di noi, coesi, uniti.
Tutti con questa convinzione:
che lo stare insieme
è la differenza, fa la differenza.
Ecco: questa foto, poi,
la lascio un attimo di sfondo
perché è significativa, anche,
di una scelta che ho voluto
affrontare in questa casa,
e che già vi dà l'input
di cosa significhi stare in questa casa
e della concezione del tempo
che c'è in questa casa,
che è un luogo di lavoro:
noi stiamo in ciabatte o a piedi scalzi.
È la prima regoletta
quando si entra in casa.
E questo non solo, così,
per un rispetto del luogo -
e per una regola igienica,
perché, insomma,
non serve che vi spieghi io
tutto quello che portiamo
sotto le scarpe, no?
Ma, fondamentalmente, perché?
Perché è il primo segnale
che qua dentro, in questo luogo di lavoro,
lo spazio, il tempo,
si dilata talmente tanto -
e questo viene consentito, anche,
dal semplice gesto
di togliersi le scarpe -
che il tempo proprio si dilata.
Non ci si rende conto
di quanto tempo
stia passando effettivamente.
Immagino che tutti voi, stasera,
quando arriverete a casa
la prima cosa che farete
sarà togliervi le scarpe.
Chissà quanti, tra i presenti in sala,
non vedono già l'ora di farlo.
Perché, insomma, tenere il piede
costretto in queste scarpe
non è poi così piacevole.
Quindi immaginate
in un ambiente di lavoro.
Dovrebbe provare, magari, qualche azienda.
Certo, non in tutti gli ambienti di lavoro
questo è possibile; però in molti sì.
È un'educazione che si può acquisire
in primis a casa e poi
nel proprio ambiente di lavoro:
è una scelta.
Così come ho scelto,
proprio perché le fiabe, da sempre,
appartengono al mio nutrimento personale,
di avere all'interno di questa casa
immagini che appartengono
al mondo delle fiabe.
Appartengono al mondo
delle illustrazioni, dei racconti;
e sono immagini che comunicano,
molto più di tante belle parole.
Questa, in primis, è un'immagine
che è all'interno della casa
e che comunica proprio quello
che vogliamo portare
in questo spazio di lavoro
come concetto fondamentale.
Perché la gente che viene
in questo spazio di lavoro
arriva per prendersi del tempo
e per prendersi cura di sé.
Sia per lavorare, in un ambiente
estremamente piacevole;
sia semplicemente per staccare la spina:
vengo lì perché ho bisogno,
ho bisogno di staccare la spina
e di arrivare in questa
piccola oasi di pace
che è proprio nel cuore di Udine.
E quindi questa immagine,
che porta proprio la mano verso il cuore
è quello che stiamo facendo nel concreto
dopo anni e anni e anni
di tanto fantasticare, tanto sognare -
sei anni, per l'esattezza.
E anch'io, come Alice, vi posso garantire
che mi sono sentita,
mi sono trovata, come lei, confusa,
a non saper dove andare,
che strada pigliare;
e soprattutto mi sono trovata anch'io,
come Alice, molte volte a piangere.
A piangere perché, fondamentalmente?
Perché mi ostinavo
a voler far capire alle persone
quello che io avevo in testa
e far capire alle persone
un progetto così complesso
non è molto semplice,
soprattutto quando questo progetto
è solo ancora nella mia testa,
era ancora nella mia testa,
e non è ancora tangibile,
non lo si può vedere.
Mi arrabbiavo da morire,
e mi son fatta tanti pianti.
Fino a quando ho detto:
"Basta! Basta innervosirmi!
Basta tutto questo voler, per forza,
far capire agli altri
quello che è nella mia testa."
Quindi, cosa ci vuole?
Ci vuole un cambiamento,
e questo cambiamento può avvenire
solo dopo un periodo di calma,
un periodo di silenzio,
nel quale, perlomeno io, ho compreso
che il mio mondo favoloso,
che era quello delle fiabe,
si può concretamente portare,
poi, nella vita reale;
e questa immagine,
che è l'immagine che c'è
all'ingresso della casa,
è l'immagine che meglio trasmette
proprio questo concetto
e che molto rimanda anche
al mondo di Alice,
dove tutto è sottosopra, è allo specchio.
Dove la logica è l'analogica,
dove l'adulto e il bambino,
l'alto e il basso, il piccolo e il grande,
si contrappongono
ma anche si corrispondono.
Questo è possibile
realizzarlo, concretamente:
Bisogna volerlo,
bisogna cominciare a guardare il mondo
con occhi diversi,
da una prospettiva diversa,
come comunica chiaramente questa immagine.
Questa immagine stava sotto
un bellissimo calendario
con una frase famosa di Churchill
che diceva, che dice:
"Non sempre cambiare
equivale a migliorare,
ma per migliorare bisogna cambiare."
Questa frase mi ha inseguita per mesi,
prima di affrontare questo cambiamento,
fino a che poi ho detto:
"È arrivato il momento,
Silvia: sei pronta."
"Sei pronta."
Tutto questo essere pronta
parte da che cosa, però?
Parte da una scelta
che avviene ancora a monte.
che è stata ancora tanti anni fa.
Si sceglie.
Si sceglie che cosa
si vuole fare nella vita,
che ruolo si vuole avere nella vita;
ma soprattutto si sceglie
se ci si vuole stupire.
Si, io ho scelto che voglio essere
al mondo per stupirmi;
ma perché ho scelto questo?
Perché mi sono accorta, negli anni,
che c'è motivo di stupirsi ogni giorno.
Ogni giorno, se sappiamo guardare il mondo
con gli occhi del mondo favoloso
a cui ci educano le fiabe,
i racconti, i cartoni animati -
io sono nata e cresciuta
con le fiabe e con i racconti,
e questo mi hanno insegnato.
Ancora mi nutro di fiabe,
di racconti e di cartoni animati,
e questo mi insegnano:
che ci si può stupire,
meravigliare, ogni giorno.
Perché l'immedesimarsi, poi,
nell'eroe, nella principessa -
chi di noi non l'ha mai fatto, da bambini?
Non posso credere che nessuno di voi
non l'abbia mai fatto,
leggendo o ascoltando un racconto.
Immedesimarsi in un ruolo
fantastico e favoloso
aiuta, agevola la vita,
e ci fa affrontare le cose
in un modo molto più semplice.
Che è quello che appartiene
al mondo delle fiabe,
al tempo delle fiabe;
ma lo si può portare, anche,
alla vita di tutti i giorni.
Le fiabe dovremmo riprenderle in mano
un po' tutti, da adulti;
e quindi non solo educare i bambini -
è molto semplice, con i bambini,
molto più diretto:
noi, da adulti,
dobbiamo riprenderci in mano le fiabe,
o guardare più cartoni animati,
perché le fiabe, i cartoni,
hanno molto da trasmetterci.
Tutto questo, sicuramente,
è una parte che comunque, credo,
sia un po' innata in me da sempre.
E quindi, tutto questo
essere in me innato,
questo mondo,
questo sentire di appartenere
sia al mondo reale
ma anche a qualcosa di favoloso,
che non è tangibile,
sicuramente in me era innato.
E questo essere innato, poi,
non lascia spazio a indugi.
E quindi, quando giunge il momento,
è il momento di agire.
Vorrei dirvi anche questo:
che il sognare ad occhi aperti
non significa essere fuori dal mondo,
lo risottolineo.
Anche se io mi sono sentita dire
per molti anni, spesso e volentieri:
"Ma cosa fa questa? Ma è pazza?
Ma che idea ha in testa?
Ma chi glielo fa fare?"
Più e più volte me lo sono sentita dire.
E... d'accordo, ok, ho lasciato correre.
Ho smesso di continuare a sentire,
di fermarmi a sentire queste voci;
e ho pensato, semplicemente,
di seguire quello che era dentro di me,
quello che mi diceva l'istinto:
"Silvia, il tuo mondo è quello.
Cerca di realizzarlo,
di portarlo nel concreto."
E così ho fatto: ho realizzato un luogo
dove appunto le persone,
adulti e bambini, si incontrano.
Creiamo progetti, creiamo proposte
di crescita, di benessere.
E le persone stanno bene.
Stanno talmente bene
che veramente, vi garantisco:
il tempo passa, ma non ci si rende conto
di quanto tempo,
effettivamente, stia passando;
E poi, fondamentalmente, perché no?
Perché non farlo?
Perché non creare qualche cosa di bello
che fa star bene le persone?
Un sì, quando è sì,
risponde sì ad un altro sì!
Ed è stato così.
E questo parte, ancora,
da un cammino mio personale
che poi porto dentro questo insieme,
questo spazio di insieme
che è iniziato dieci anni fa
quando sono partita per il Giappone
per un'esperienza di volontariato.
Conosciuta per caso,
perché casualmente ho conosciuto
il Servizio Civile Internazionale.
E questo Paese da sempre mi chiamava,
perché poi succede anche così:
le cose ti chiamano,
e poi bisogna effettivamente seguirle.
E così ho fatto.
Sono partita per questo Paese,
che da anni mi chiamava.
Ma non volevo andare in questo Paese
come una classica turista;
e soprattutto, anche,
non potevo permettermelo
perché è un Paese alquanto impegnativo.
E quindi ho detto: "Parto."
E molte persone, mia madre compresa,
dicevano, pensavano:
"Oddio questa non torna più,
questa rimane là."
E invece no:
sono partita,
ho fatto questa bellissima
esperienza di volontariato,
e sono tornata con proprio quello
di cui avevo bisogno
che era il motore
per tornare, fare, agire,
qua nel mio Paese.
Quel Paese cosa mi ha insegnato?
Fondamentalmente, mi ha insegnato
una cosa bellissima,
che è il senso di gratitudine.
Devo ringraziare perché sono
una persona estremamente fortunata.
Fortunata perché ho ricevuto tanto,
e in primis ho ricevuto, ho avuto sempre
la possibilità di scegliere
quello che volevo fare,
che è una grandissima libertà.
Di scegliere che esperienza fare,
di scegliere che lavoro fare;
e questa libertà,
sicuramente, non è da tutti.
È una libertà che comunque
ci si conquista, anche;
ci si conquista anche con lacrime
e con qualche porta
chiusa in faccia: più d'una.
È una libertà che poi nel tempo, comunque,
una volta diventata madre -
ahimé, devo dire - ho sentito meno.
Perché a quel tempo sono diventata madre
ed ero libera professionista:
ed essere madre
e libera professionista insieme
non è poi una passeggiata.
Io sono stata fortunata, anche,
perché avevo due nonne favolose:
le ho ancora.
E mi potevano garantire un supporto
che non tutti obiettivamente hanno;
però vi garantisco
che lasciare il proprio figlio a tre mesi
per dover tornare a lavorare,
perché così è stato,
non è stata cosa semplice.
Quindi c'era poco da lasciarsi incantare
dallo sguardo del proprio bambino:
non c'era tempo.
E dentro di me è cominciato
proprio in quel momento, credo,
a nascere questo desiderio
di creare un qualche cosa
di diverso livello lavorativo
dove si potesse coniugare
il tempo famiglia,
le necessità che una famiglia ha,
un neogenitore ha con un bambino,
soprattutto piccolo,
con una dimensione lavorativa
che consenta di vivere
insieme al proprio figlio.
E questo è possibile.
Quindi, in questo spazio
di lavoro che ho creato,
è possibile lavorare
e contemporaneamente, per chi vuole,
avere il proprio figlio in età di nido
a pochi passi dal proprio ufficio,
con un educatrice,
in uno spazio in tutta sicurezza,
a misura di bambino.
E quindi lavorare serenamente,
con i tempi e la voglia di maternità
è possibile.
Questo dovrebbe essere più possibile,
in più realtà, in più aziende;
fondamentalmente, questo è successo
perché c'è sempre stato
un pensiero, in me,
costruito nel tempo
dalle esperienze di volontariato -
perché poi ho anche aperto
un'associazione di volontariato,
e per dieci anni noi ci siamo occupati
di progetti di sostegno
alla genitorialità e all'infanzia.
Adesso questa associazione cresce,
e si sviluppa ogni giorno,
dentro lo spazio di lavoro che ho creato
perché credo fondamentalmente
che il mondo profit e il mondo no profit
debbano stare insieme
per creare sviluppo e progettualità nuove.
Perché se diffondiamo cose belle
il mondo si occupa
di portare cose ancora migliori,
ed è proprio così:
nella mia vita è sempre stato così.
Ho diffuso e ho creato
tantissime belle cose
di cui la gente ancora oggi mi ringrazia;
ma me ne sono arrivate,
sempre, molte di più.
È per questo che io
devo dire grazie ogni giorno,
e lo dico effettivamente.
Dico grazie per tutto quello
che ho ricevuto,
grazie per le possibilità
che mi stanno arrivando,
e per le persone che sono insieme con me,
che credono in questo modo
di stare insieme
perché questo è possibile.
Quindi, questo spazio di insieme
può avvenire da un sogno,
da un sogno che è insito:
basta che uno di voi sogni,
come ho fatto io,
che si ispiri guardando il cielo,
guardando la Luna;
e che poi però torni nel proprio silenzio
a guardare la Terra,
perché i sogni si possono realizzare.
Quindi mi auguro veramente
di avere, anche solo un po',
contagiato qualcuno di voi
e che magari, chi lo sa:
nei prossimi giorni, nei prossimi mesi,
qualcuno di voi possa veramente
concretizzare i propri sogni
come ho fatto io.
Grazie per avermi ascoltato.
Abbiate cura dei vostri sogni:
prendetevi il tempo,
perché i sogni hanno bisogno di tempo
per essere poi realizzati.
Grazie.
(Applausi)